awesome cool so gonna talk about
approximate nearest neighbors
I built a library called annoy when I
was at Spotify is this better is this
necessary is this necessary
alright cool let's do this three mics so
I'm gonna cover a couple of different
things so sorry the background noise I
built a thing called the noise to work
at Spotify for five years and built is
saying that lets you do approximate
nearest neighbor search in high
dimensional spaces I'm gonna talk about
that but also give you a lot of
background about why I think vector
models are awesome and you should use
them for everything and also how I know
it works and talk a bit about the
challenges and how I built it but so
first it's gonna be a little bit more
background about vector models before
that like something for about me I built
another sinkhole luigi's it's like
nothing with machine learning is data
data plumbing tool Python working on a
small startup that's the CTO called
better we work with mortgages and yeah
so as fire risk that's modified man it's
a machine learning team a couple of
those peoples are here in the front you
should talk to them if you're interested
in Spotify so that's it about me so
let's talk about nearest neighbors so
nearest neighbors when I refer to that I
talked about I refer to like I mean like
points right so you start with a set of
points in some space and yeah so in this
case two-dimensional space and a bunch
of points right kind of a trivial
example here like typically have in the
applications that I've been working on
like millions and millions of points and
in high dimensional spaces this joke is
getting old now but like it's hard to
fit like a high dimensional space in a
two-dimensional projector but so that's
why it's all two-dimensional today so
what is nearest neighbor it means it
means
we're gonna search some part of the
space we're gonna like query for some
point here some it's blue
I don't can see that and we're gonna
look around for the points that are
closest to it so kind of simple like
that's the basic idea and it sounds like
kind of like almost silly but turns out
it's actually a super useful in a lot of
cases this is five nearest neighbors you
know you can go hard are cool yeah so
what's the point
and what I'm arguing is that turns out
vector ER models are awesome and as soon
as you have a vector model you have a
bunch of points in some space and you
want to use nearest neighbors too
you want to search for nearest neighbors
into space so let's talk about some
vector models and I'm gonna start with
like a super simple example here is you
know the canonical machine earnings data
set M inist it's like sixty thousand
handwritten digits they're all 28 by 28
grayscale so so why is this a vector
space right like you can you can take
these pixels the 78-84 pixels and kind
of smash them and just make them it's a
big vector and you get this 784
dimensional space right 28 by 28 okay so
now we have 60,000 points in a 784
dimensional space so now we define a
distance function okay and in this case
we're gonna make it simple we're just
going to define it as a squared
Euclidean distance right so there's sum
of the squares of the differences for
each pixel okay that make sense fix it
cool so now we have a distance function
and we can take two of these pictures to
these digits and we can compute a
distance
awesome let me know if you have
questions by the way I'm wearing happy
to like take questions during the talk
we can talk more afterwards as well cool
so so what well you can do now is since
we define the distance function we can
actually rank we can take a digit and we
can rank all the other ones based on how
close they are in this 784 dimensional
space and so this is exactly what I did
here on the left side we have various
randomly sampled digits and on the right
side I'm showing it at 10 most similar
digits from this data set so you kind of
see visually make sense like we're
finding visually similar images right
you know like for a human it might not
make sense because like some of the
digits are weird like this is 8 but
we're finding a 5 and we're kind of
mixing up the sixes and zeroes but it's
like they're like visually the same
right and that's the point so so we
effectively built a like image search
engine and just like super small space
of 28 by 28 pixels right I said so
that's cool so now we can you know if
you wanted to do like digit
classification you can train like a cane
heirs neighborhood eye classifier in
this space you can take a new image you
can look around it find a top 10 closest
once and just take the majority of
whatever something like that
cool so the problem is like let's say we
actually want to scale this let's say we
want to do this for arbitrary images or
for works or whatever I'm gonna talk
about texts and other things later but
let's say we actually want to do this
for bigger images the problem is we have
a 7 it's older you like high high number
of dimensions right 784 and say we
wanted to go to like thousand by
thousand images right and there's like
three colors too so we get it's like
three million dimensional space so plus
like similarity in this in this space
isn't like perfect like if you want to
like if you have two pictures of dogs
and one dog is like lower left corner
and then the other picture the dog is
the upper right corner like they're not
have gonna have like a high like pixel
by pixel similarity but for human
they're pretty similar so so what I'm
gonna like what I'm arguing is that this
is recurrent thing is that almost always
you want to start with some fairly high
dimensional space you want to do
dimensionality reduction down to like a
small dimensional space and in the small
dimensional space that's where you want
to do similarity search by using
something like a toy
so again start with super high
dimensional data you know three million
dimensional data in the case of thousand
by thousand pixels you reduce it down
somehow by some magic function and now
you have like a small dimensional space
like a hundred dimensions or ten or
whatever and you're gonna do cool stuff
in this this place cool so so here it's
kind of a here's something I I was
playing around I want to learn
convolutional neural network so I wasted
a lot of thousands of dollars on renting
GPU instances when Amazon I had this
crazy idea I was gonna I don't know I
wanted this kind of silly I wanted to
build an app that that would predict the
calorie content from food pictures it
didn't work out because I ran out of
time and had to do other things and but
I know I ended up training a machine
learning model that at least it can take
a picture of food and predict what food
it is it actually works so is it to do
that I downloaded 6 million pictures of
food from Yelp I just scraped and a
Foursquare and a training a vice model
that takes a picture that's 156 point
156 and then runs it through this deep
neural network and on the other side
it's going to predict words in the
description text okay so in this case if
it's like spicy ramen it's gonna predict
some like a1 in the position for spicy
and the one in the position for ramen
it's like you know multi classification
problem here
anyway that doesn't really matter it
turns out that you know the coolest
thing about this is like I have a layer
here that's 128 dimensional which turns
out to be perfect it's like now we're
training and embedding from food down to
128 dimensional space okay so for any
food picture now or for any picture
actually we we've learned a function
that you know it takes a burger and
outputs vector a and I was gonna say
yeah so and and you know machine
learning is always about learning
functions right in this case we're in a
neural network that learned this
function from you know burger to some
vector and fries to some other vector
and turns out in this space for various
reasons cosine distance is a little bit
better it just means we're gonna
normalize these things these are vectors
now so we're going to compute the
squared Euclidean the worm of between
the normalized vectors but it's
essentially something cool tuck so what
does nearest neighbors look like in this
space pretty cool you know it actually
works pretty well right so on the left
side again I put in various like
randomly sampled pictures from Yelp and
then I just look for like the most
similar food pictures out of a database
of six million pictures and it's like
super fast to it because I'm gonna talk
later about how we do this search using
annoy you can do this in milliseconds so
we built the effectively a you know
image search engine for food pictures so
it's just kind of useless but kind of
fun okay so do you know put in fries to
get fries back the cool thing I was like
you can see like you know that the color
you don't really see it on this
projector but the color is like quite
different for all the fries like that
you know there's like a little bit
different scale I like positions like
these fries are much closer to the
camera I think the other one this one is
a better example of that like you have
these like small Asian there's like
Asian food in white balls
agent papa ara and you know you can see
the balls are like located in different
places you know this is different scale
it's different stuff in them but we've
learned some how to project these to
look very similar 128 dimensional
feature vectors and I think the coolest
one is this is like random deserts with
you know patterns of chocolate over it
and look and I don't even know if the
desserts are that similar but the
chocolate you know the way they like
sprinkle the chocolate is kind of
similar for all of them so it's kind of
cool it kind of works so this is an
example of a dimension dimensionality
reduction right like we started with
these the these high dimensional items
in this case pictures that are 156 by
156 by 3 and we reduce it down to like a
super small vector that's like
represents those pictures you have a
question
learning
are you saying I'm using supervised yeah
you have the information to help you to
party the biggest dimension
right right so it's the point is he's
making its this is supervisor I've been
super blessed because he had target
we're trying to predict some quanta in
this case food categories but when we're
actually computing the distances like
we're it's there's there's no there's no
cheating at all right like we're not
using the description text when we're
computing this the distances that's
purely based on the pixels right this
gives is in this gives us an embedding
into 128 dimensional space you can do
this onto in an unsupervised way too
it's just harder because then I you know
I think going from pictures to
descriptive text you know it's a way to
tell the Machine what we're actually
looking for if you do it like purely
unsupervised the machine might just
learn that like there's a huge variation
in the color in this top right corner
right but probably does it matter
cool so this was food you can do this
for text you know this this is actually
an old field you know this is worth
Tyvek now like people think that's
really cool but it's actually been going
on for a long time but but there's been
like lately a lot of new models
particular recurred neural networks and
long short-term memory and stuff but if
it did you know it has a long history
and and what all these things have in
common is we're starting with some
corpus or something and we're finding
these slow dimensional representations
of words and documents right so we're
we're taking words and we're projecting
them down to some space that lets us
that captures semantic similarity right
so in this reduced space in just small
dimensional space words that are similar
enough close to each other it's kind of
a silly example like apple and banana or
similar boats less similar that that's
that's the idea right and and this works
all right you just need a lot of
training data big corpus of text you can
do this for documents too
I've I spent a couple of years that
Spotify doing exactly this for
collaborative filtering so for music
recommendations we find a representation
in the low dimensional space for like
music tracks but also for users and
playlists and artists and albums and
stuff this is you know a lot of a lot of
matrix factorization methods came out of
the Netflix price they're all supervised
Spotify were typically at unsupervised
turns out on supervises this is
essentially equivalent to an LP natural
and language processing you're looking
at it like a playlist as a document
you're looking at the tracks in that
playlist as a series of words and then
you can run something like word Tyvek
like word Tyvek works really well for
music recommendations so you know here's
them I talked about this topic a bunch
the time so if you're interested you can
just go go there's a lot of slides
online about this this is just some old
material that I recycle here's another
example kind of like a Sunday hack
project I did a couple of weeks ago I I
just like pinged random IP addresses and
just measured how long it take takes to
get result and did a geoip look up to
long lat and then you convert that to a
point on the unit sphere and you do like
K nearest neighbors regression on that
so so this is like speed of know you
know you can see like in New York like
where I live like it's close
you know if I ping addresses and
on a tie line it's kind of slow it's
kind of fun so this is my point here
it's just like you can also use this for
like physical like you know it doesn't
have to be a latent space right all this
previous example in space you know you
can actually use this for physical space
- right and in this case three
dimensional so this is kind of fun and
this is like you know 50 lines of Python
okay so let's talk about how we're
actually gonna do nearest neighbor
search so I built a little thing that
lets you do that fast and why do you
want to do this fast because you know if
you like you know it's like the
alternative is doing exhaustive search
right you can always fall back to
exhaustive search you have a point set
of 10 million points and you want to
find the nearest ones like the most like
dumb way to do that is if you did search
through all of them compute the distance
and just rank them right but for a lot
of you know and a lot of practical
applications that is is way too slow
right
you know Spotify computes
recommendations for on 50 million people
every day by doing a search in the you
know this high dimensional space you
know you can't do exhaustive search do
you do something faster thing so how do
you do that you know actually sorry I'm
just gonna talk about this this is
exhaustive search so we're Tyvek comes
with a tool to do exhaustive search so
you know you put in Chinese River on
some pre train vectors and you get back
a bunch of Chinese rivers it's kind of
cool like in this latent factored space
of words takes two and a half minutes to
do that so I wrote that to use annoy and
annoy yet talked about this but one cool
feature about annoy is the uses M map so
you can like map it from this very
quickly into RAM but you know realize on
the page cache in Linux or in any kernel
so okay so I we're up this in annoy and
like you know half a second right so 250
times faster did anyone notice something
though
different right actually the numbers of
the different because I I hope output
I'm outputting the wrong numbers but
more so that doesn't really matter but
more importantly we're not finding
actually the exact same things you know
go back
so it's not exactly and you know and and
and that's fine in a lot of cases we
want to trade off a little bit of
accuracy for performance so this is 250
times faster and we're losing a couple
of rivers in China right turns out you
can actually tweak the knobs a little
bit and annoy and search a little bit
longer and now we're spending two
seconds and we're finding exactly the
same results right yeah a little bit
lucky but works cool so our chart
so how do you how do you do this right
so there's two steps like there's some
sort of magic data structure in Bolton
here so first I'm going to talk about
how to build this big data structure
we're going to pre-compute the data
structure and as you might know from
computer science there's only like two
data structures really like you kind of
can reduce everything to two days
structures there's there's trees and
there's hashes hashmaps okay so we're
gonna use binary trees actually okay so
so here's how you build an annoy
structure the data structure that lets
you do approximate nearest neighbor
researcher here's our noise there's many
ways but this is what I like to do you
start with a set of points again
two-dimensional not so many because it'd
be hard to see and we're gonna split it
like randomly in two subsets and and the
way we do that and this is just
heuristic aliy it seems to work is that
we pick two random points you know this
one and this one and and then we split
it by the hyperplane that's equidistant
from those points okay so make sense so
now we have the first split in this
binary tree right let's split it again
okay so now we have four notes keep
splitting
and eventually we end up with something
that does we keep splitting until we
have oh my golly
Dexter is like does not like this color
it should be blue
anyway we keep splitting till we have
you know K K items left in each leaf and
the point is is that the binary tree is
a lot more space efficient that way
right so here's the binary tree so you
know now we have a tree here all the
squares are run a random hyper place and
the leaves these circles are it's a
small set of points so I don't know if
you can see they have numbers in them
cool so we actually built the binary
tree of this set of points right and the
theory is that points that are similar
in this original space this original
space if you take a random hyperplane if
two points are very close to each other
they're very unlikely to end up on the
wrong side of that split like if we have
two points and we split it like most
like sorry sorry I even said 300 most
likely we're not going to like split
like right between those right so so the
point of this binary tree is if two
points are close and the original space
they're gonna end up being pretty close
to each other in this binary tree right
so that's nice it would be kind of
preserves distance that's somehow
roughly
searching okay so this is you know this
is kind of simple now you start with
your query point okay sorry and call
this I messed up again you start with
your query point and just like navigate
down the tree and for every of these
hyperplanes intermediate nodes we just
go on the side that this query point and
stop being on okay okay so what's the
problem here
there's a problem here's the problem
yeah oh [ __ ] it's two problems that
projector and and high dimensional news
everything so the problem here is we
search for something who ended up in
this little polygon here and and as you
can see there's actually points that are
like on the other side of the slit
that's actually really close to them
because we would like just went down to
the buyer tree so we're gonna do we're
gonna do something else we're gonna
extend the bot the binary the search a
little bit so that if we're very close
to any of these hyper planes we're
actually gonna go on both sides okay so
let's do like this right you know now
instead of only going through it down
here we're also going down here cuz it
turns out this slit up here has a very
small margin okay
so cool so now we end up with these
points like bigger set of points yeah
and how to do that you know I've
experimented with various heuristics I
don't I don't know why certain things
work if you know benchmark the button
and seems like certain things work
better than other I don't know why I
said happy okay cool
and it turns out you can actually
generalize this really well by instead
of like having like an arbitrary like
epsilon or whatever like you can
actually put use a party Q to kind of
dynamically expand like industry you
kind of first you look at all the you
know positive margins and then you kind
of expand this or looking at slightly
negative margins and you kind of dude
from there so you put all the internal
notes and a priority queue and then pop
them and put them on a consider sorry
about the second trick we're gonna do is
we're not just gonna construct one tree
we're gonna construct many trees and
that's called a forest right so and this
idea is that maybe like the first tree
was like we were kind of unlucky maybe
we had two points in that space and we
randomly like ended up separating them
right so we're gonna construct the
second tree randomly and the whole point
of constructing trees randomly is just D
correlate them so so that means that
maybe if like we're unlucky the first
time for some specific point maybe in
the second tree we're select the it
slightly more fortunate so this is what
it looks like so this is the same point
set and we construct three random trees
and now if we search down the the binary
tree that we give different results and
this in this last case actually is this
leaf polygon was slightly better than
the other ones because we didn't have to
even go on the other side of any splits
so we're gonna do that and typically the
more trees the better like you can
construct up to like hundreds or
thousands of G's if you want to and and
the cool thing is with this priority
queue it really generalizes really well
to multiple trees because you can search
multiple trees at the same time using
the same priority queue what Billy's
gonna do is it's gonna like find which
tree is like is the best which are the
splits that are like the farthest away
from me and like focus on those trees
the only thing is it take more round
with more trees so you can only add
trees up to certain limit okay so so you
know now we've got all the basic pieces
in place let's talk about how actually
we do this you know this is so so so
first we we search all these trees using
a party queue then we're gonna since we
have many trees like the same item of
course and different in like multiple
trees in all trees so we're gonna remove
the duplicates now we have a set of
points left maybe like a thousand now
we're actually gonna go and compute the
the real distance for them and then
we're gonna sort it and return to the
top ten or whatever so so first we've
got and find candidates you know using
these binary trees then we take the
Union and here's the when we end up with
we take every of these leaves are convex
polygons so if you take the Union it
actually turns out to be non convex so
so we end up with this set of candidates
compute the distances for all these
candidates and then we return the top
time or
in this case I think it was top three
okay so pretty good like it works pretty
well you know I I intentionally made it
as a kind of a trigger case because
there's actually one or two points that
we didn't catch right like the there's a
couple of points up here that we
actually missed and one here but you
generally get the good points right and
and again this goes back to like this is
why it's called approximate nearest
neighbors like we we are not going to
guarantee that we get all of them which
actually turns out to be an np-complete
problem in high dimensional spaces but
we're trading off a little bit of
accuracy in return for like you know
hundred or thousand x performance
improvements right
let's talk about something slightly
related to that which is the curse of
dimensionality right there's this theory
that predicts that in high dimensional
spaces we get just like weird phenomena
where like the notion of like a
neighborhood kind of disappears and and
here's here's like artificial data I
just pulled data from and like a
k-dimensional lauren normal distribution
so what happens is like if you pick a
random point in his distribution and
look at like how far is the my nearest
neighbor and my furthest neighbor turns
out in like two dimensions it's it's
it's very different right
but if you go to thousand dimensions
it's very similar so so why is this
counter to it it's like you know think
of like a world map right like in two
dimensions you know that this is from
New York too you know Washington is very
small but the distance from New York to
Beijing is raised huge let's say that
the earth was a thousand dimensions then
the distance to every city would be
almost the same it's like really bizarre
so that's what happened in in in
thousand dimensions if you like use like
a normal distribution and here's a
here's like a world map right and this
is this is a Voronoi tessellation if we
start with a random point said we can we
can do a born artist solution they look
kinda cool and in if you look at the
neighborhood graph which is called a de
l'année triangulation I think if you
think of this as a map like you know
most countries only border like one or
two other countries or three or five or
whatever in thousand dimensional cone in
a thousand dimensional world map like
every country would be we have a border
shared with every other country roughly
so this is sort of like weird things
that happen in high dimensional spaces
okay so this doesn't mean we're screwed
so maybe yeah it definitely means that
things are harder and you can actually
there's some proof that doing well you
cannot do exact nearest neighbor search
in less than linear time in high
dimensional spaces there's also this
theory that says since this quantity
goes to 0 right but so so let's see what
happens when we actually look at real
data you know this this is synthetic
data from a normal distribution and then
we are I'll actually look at some real
data you know various word vectors
various you know this is this is the
food vectors we got the digit here so at
least using this quantity which is kind
of arguable you can see that the data
behaves as if it's actually low
dimensional so we have a thousand
dimensional set of points but it's
effectively behaving if you look at this
free basic vectors which is a thousand
dimensions it's behaving as if it's 15
dimensions so that's kind of cool and
the way I think about it's like yeah
like if you have a map of all the
citizens in the world they they are in
three-dimensional space but for
practical purposes like they kind of
behave as if they're like two
dimensional right because everything is
on a surface so I think that's what
happens in these high dimensional spaces
it turns out some of the mentions matter
very little just as like altitude
matters that are very little on the
surface of the earth like what really
matters is like one or two shows
so this is kind of cool and I think this
is for me this is proof why annoy
actually works although it shouldn't
work or any of these approximate nearest
neighbor methods is that if you actually
have some awareness of the distribution
then you can kind of you can you can
still you can still search for nearest
neighbors in this space
cool another thing that I I kind of like
about Illinois is that it's not just
about like improving accuracy or
improving performance an improvement in
accuracy actually you can kind of
reinterpret that as a performance and as
an improvement in performance so you
have this like weird case which which I
think it's fun where I can choose to
like and build my machine learning
algorithms better and that could improve
accuracy but I can also like think about
how the page cache works or how the CPU
cache works and that means I can search
more notes and that means I can actually
get more accuracy so it's kind of like
you know like a chess ala right like
that's why people are so obsessed with
like bid maps and [ __ ] when they when
they try to ride fast chess a eyes it's
more than just having smart algorithms
is also like being like fast right so
I've spent a little bit of time
optimizing annoy I did a benchmark
against a couple other libraries so I
think we're two top four so you can
check it out so I know it's actually not
the fastest one it's like half as fast
sometimes but when you get to this you
know at some point over here like high
accuracy which i think is like practical
setting is actually the most important
case when you want like 95% accuracy
turns out I know it's actually the best
one in this data set for this data set
at least but but there's a couple of
other ones that work a little bit
different
cool um there's and there's two
trade-offs with the Noi one is like any
more trees and you don't want it's like
you just sort of in runtime search for
more nodes but um yeah you can explore
that and um I'm sort of wrapping up now
but just want to mention a couple of
things I've tried a lot of things to
improve this there's a lot of things
that that worked more things that didn't
work but a couple of things that worked
is you know thinking about how to split
planes and CPU caches and things like
that there's a lot of things that didn't
work I spent like a lot of time trying
to do like 8-bit floating points every
spin take it doesn't really work for
some reason I don't you know a lot more
things I want to do in the future
I wish I had more time but uh if you
have time to actually help me I'd love
to chat afterwards I realized the other
day that like it would be really cool to
support edit distance because it turns
out at Noah actually doesn't really rely
on like having like a sort of Euclidean
space you can actually have so like
arbitraries and functions so that would
kind of cool a lot of stuff funded but
yeah that's it go check out annoying I
put the benchmarks up this whole
presentation most of it is actually open
source all the scripts that generate the
slides you care which I got my blog
forum and Twitter and that's it and
we're hiring by the way just in case
so if you're interested if you're
looking for a job just definitely cool
thanks a lot you have any questions yep
what's that the priority creature a six
so so the way it works is right now is
let me let me go back to like how binary
tree looks like okay yeah let's go back
all the way to this one this one okay so
the heuristics what I mean with that is
you know every every point here when you
search you're gonna compute a margin and
but you know so so you want some
heuristic that's based on like the
margin at every of these steps and I
tried the sum it didn't work as well as
is using the minimum margin of this I
don't know why does that make any sense
it's magic to me like I'm sure it isn't
like my you know mathematical reason why
but you know so you want some sort of
heuristic it's kind of like a star
search I guess you have some like
heuristic to like prioritize how you
search in this space preserving it just
turns out that like the minimum
violation of ORS are that the max
violation of how far you go into the
other side of any slit is the best
heuristic I don't want cool any other
questions
I'm surprised you didn't use the normal
term for this people invitation to be
locality-sensitive hashing yeah yeah so
the question is about locality sensitive
hashing I've tried that I've never got
it to work well well well cavity
sensitive hashing it doesn't construct a
tree right it only construct a set of
hashes directly from the point set which
side randomized hyperplane
right read certain see read to and so
that becomes in this case a hash
function drawn from a series of binary
balanced gray very exactly using a
binary you know a binary right right so
this is the point of locality sensitive
hashing is instead of building a tree
you just have a bunch of root nodes and
you just compute what side of the root
nodes the point falls on this is
decorate right and and then you get a
binary representation that you know
represents any point in this space as a
binary string and then you can use that
to to to hash
I never I've never you know my
experiments was I never got it to work
well I I suspect it has something to do
with the fact that it's not really aware
of the distribution of points it's just
using random splits so you know if you
have a thousand dimensional distribution
and it turns out that the points are
mostly spread out along one axis a lot
of those random splits are just going to
be like not contribute any information
at all and that's my experience I don't
know a lot of people use
locality-sensitive hashing I've haven't
really seen it work well for the stuff
that I've been doing
cool more questions
just to follow up slightly on that the
point that you are making about the
impact of datasets that you've seen
isn't that just classical sparsity so in
other words you know over sufficiently
high dimensional spaces that you're
still getting a you know a large
clunking of the data into you know that
the actually the actual distances
between these between these data points
in high dimensional space are actually
relatively flat so you product you know
either
I either you've got sparsity so you've
got much high dimensionality have you
data points being written
I'm not sure I understand the question
like typical you have like more and
ending in the things that I've been
looking at you have far more points than
dimensions but but I still think it's
it's not a matter of like lack of data
if that's what you meant right right I
think the way the reason why the
conditions where will Cal their
sensitive hash hashing works is if you
have like a normal distribution like
it's put it there's have it in reality
in most cases you have some high
dimensional set of points and there is
some underlying distribution that
generated those points we just don't
know that distribution and in that case
if that distribution has like high
regularities then I think LSH else to
take advantage of those words if you
construct a binary tree you're sort of
dynamically discovering that those that
structure cool more questions yeah
how does the algorithm outliers out
Lowery's I think actually worked really
well if you think about how boring on a
diagram looks like like I think you know
in the edges of these it's it's pretty
far in between these you know these
these fields get bigger and bigger so if
you're searching for some point out here
the sparsity is much higher or the
density is much lower I don't know if
that makes any sense
actually the truth is I don't know I'm
just making something up right now but I
think I think it's actually it gets
easier with outliers I think it gets
harder like in here in this like cluster
here yeah
how many trees are and abusing typically
like a hundred maybe or like ten or I
don't know ten up to hundred you know
whatever like how many you can fit in
around effective like efficiently every
tree takes some amount of space so it's
like how much RAM you have on your
computer you don't want to like one over
that because you know then you're gonna
start small thing and then you're
screwed but it but up to that more trees
generally always help
point effective is it
yes I've played around with how do you
represent these vectors like a series of
32-bit floats I tried like reduce that
position to like eight bits but it
doesn't really work I think it has
something to do with the fact that the
bottleneck is actually memory latency so
it doesn't really matter that you're
fetching less data
what matters is like you still have like
the exact same amount of random access
cache misses or a speculation all right
now but think so cool more questions the
question is how often do I update the
trick so what annoying does not support
updates the data structure is like fixed
so you pre compute it and and it is what
it is so so typically the way we did it
at Spotify was every few days we would
run like a new matrix factorization
algorithm on the listening data and you
may get Becker's and maybe compute an
annoying index and you know that was the
annoy index for a few next few days yeah
at some point I really want to support
like updates but it you know it's this
Messier
cool yep visualize
yes so the question is that about t
sneak teach me is a cool method that is
mostly it's good for visualization it
has this cool ability that it takes some
high dimensional point set and it kind
of warps it down to like two dimensions
in a way that similar items are still
close to each other I I don't know I I
have a certain multiple theories that
are like in conflict with each other I
think maybe that should work like maybe
you can take like a thousand dimensional
data set and duty Snee down to like ten
dimension before you build in or index
maybe that would work on the other hand
if the intrinsic dimensionality is older
you've pretty small then you might not
gain that much from doing tease me and
the other thing is that T Sneed there's
certain like ask your warping this space
you suddenly lose certain things like
you know you might actually have like
like Spotify did this thing where like
user vectors were computed separately
from the annoy index so now if you if
you like worked the the set of the music
space you still have these like user
vectors and you have like no idea how it
warped up because teasing doesn't learn
a function it just learns to a mapping
so that's the problem so you throwing
away information I think does that make
any sense
the question is can you use TC for
annoying 40 see if you can do that that
would be very easy implementation
teaching just load everything into the
wires
all right cool yeah yeah well there's
only two distance metrics that are
supported by noia right now the one is
Euclidean it's the kind of basic the
owner one is cosine art technically it's
like an normalized you normalize the
vectors and then do your quitting this
is so that course that's equivalent to
like cosine similarity but you know I
you know there's nothing that prevents
us from doing like Manhattan in distance
and I never know how to pronounce this
mile up and off distance or like even
like edit distance hey yep what about
computing and embedding yeah I mean you
know that's what I've been canoeing is
like you want to do some sort of
dimensionality reduction right is that
we mean like because like that's exactly
what we learned using this neural
network right we learn and embedding in
128 dimensional space where we start
from like a big dimensional space and
maybe you can do even more like maybe as
a part of annoy it can like on top of
that iteratively learn another embedding
I don't know I think that'd be very cool
to explore
a binary yeah I think I mean like last
twenty years of machine earning like the
like recipe for success has like always
been that like don't like come up with
like various heuristics actually define
a loss function and like optimize that
loss function so I think in like in the
case of annoy like I'm you know I'm
repeating the same mistake I'm just
defining a bunch of heuristics for how
the split trees I think what you really
would want to do and I think this would
like kick ass is you would learn how to
split those trees in search a way that
you minimize the divergence between the
distance in the original space and some
sort of new form of distance in these
even these forests of binary trees but
yeah you could probably figure out how
to do that I wish there's more time than
and like a I don't know more computers
more question two more minutes two more
questions two more questions
two more he wants to do the first one it
has to be very very good question no I'm
just kidding
come on
first we just do the same all right
let's do the second question all right
whatever
the current that is to say is it a date
of parallel application by or design or
you experimental II just
I'm not sure I understand equator there
are like pre-computation trade offs
which is like you can build more trees
and then there's a wrong time trade-off
which is you can you can choose how much
you want to explore in this search space
is that we meant
parallelizable how parallelizable is
this i haven't focused too much on
parallelizing it like building the index
is very parallelizable so we're just
building a bunch of binary trees and
they have nothing to do with each other
so you can just pull it all in parallel
I I haven't done that because I haven't
for me hasn't been a problem searching
is slightly less parallelizable but you
can add a mutex on the priority queue
and just have a bunch of workers in
reality that hasn't been an issue for me
because what you can do is you can just
use like in all my application I can
just use multi-processing instead
because because the noi uses m map right
so you can share a static data set
between processes you don't even have to
deal with locks so instead of
parallelizing each individual search you
just do many searches at the same time
specifically that applications that I
work with at Spotify was like batch
processing anyway so it didn't really
matter cool
what else one more question or the 0na
did we skip one okay I'll give you kind
of seconds
what am i doing now so I run the
engineering team of this small start-up
we work with mortgages building a
mortgage bank from scratch super cool
got a couple of the team here a couple
of people from the team mostly iron back
in engineers but eventually I really
want to start thinking also about
machine learning and how we can build
machine learning to predict home prices
and forecast home prices and risk models
for borrowers and there's all these like
cool machine learning problems so that's
something I want to start hiring for
later this year so if you're interested
in like mortgages and homes and American
dream with homeownership you talk
afterwards awesome thanks a lot